part of spiritual development is to
recognize the satanic tendencies that
characterize you and to fully wrestle
with them and to and to integrate them
that's the thing it's it's not so much
to cast them away it's to transmute them
you know and you can see the difference
between people who have done that and
people who haven't at least to some
degree because people who haven't
integrated the shadow at all are naive
and you can tell that when you look at
them and you can tell that when you talk
to them and because they're naive
they're often resentful as well because
they get taken advantage of and someone
who's integrated that more they're
dangerous in in the martial arts sort of
way which is they're dangerous but they
don't have to be they don't have to use
it because their presence radiates what
would you say it doesn't radiate threat
exactly well certainly strength but it's
it's it's it's the potential for havoc
that's the right way of thinking about
it
there's a there's an implicit potential
for havoc and that's really necessary
it's one of the things that gives people
self respect this is an interesting
thing about the integration of the
shadow because recognizing yourself as
the locus of evil let's say actually in
some sense gives you far more respect
for yourself strangely enough because
the same respect that you might have for
a wild animal or even a monster it's
like and though so then maybe you learn
to treat yourself differently like I
think this is particularly true with
regards to the discipline of children
you know if you know that you're a
monster
and that that will manifest itself in
your life consciously or unconsciously
and if it's unconsciously it's it's it's
not good then you become better at
disciplining children and the reason for
that is that you don't want to expose
them to your dark side and so if they
behave and don't provoke you which means
they'll also behave for other people
then you don't the monstrous part can
stay in abeyance
and then that's great but if you don't
understand yourself as capable of
wreaking havoc and that can be the kind
of havoc that unfolds over decades right
because if you're going to abuse a child
it's the primitive form of abuse is the
physical abuse the sophisticated form of
abuse is the continual undermining of
the child's courage across perhaps their
entire life and that there's a terribly
monstrous element to that and if you're
not respected properly by the child say
you will absolutely take revenge on them
and you know that's the holes in some
sense that's the whole Freudian
psychoanalytic story it's not all of it
but it's a huge part of it interesting
that you you say that you have to accept
the fact that you're dangerous or become
dangerous because I'd also say that if
you haven't done that kind of shadow
work if you haven't made friends with
your anger if you haven't integrated it
you're actually more dangerous yes then
things will happen that will it will
come out in a way that you don't expect
right it comes out disintegrated so it
comes out as an autonomous spirit right
under no one's control and that's like a
burst of rage let's say you know when
you when you hear about a mother who's
done something terrible to one of her
children it's that's the reason is that
you know she maybe she's just been laid
off maybe she went out and and had two
meant too much to drink
maybe she's hungover you know she's
she's angry and lonesome and she's
overwhelmed by the responsibility of the
children and she has a child who's
testing and she doesn't know how to
limit it and one day the child tests at
exactly the wrong time and it's like
mayhem and everybody goes well what
happened it's like well seven terrible
things came together at the same time
and produced this outburst of
disintegrated rage and like look the
hell out when that happens you know so
yeah you you want to have that you you
either have that or it has you those are
the options and you don't become safe by
being castrated